Speaker 1: Mike Pence is running for president,
one of the most electric and inspiring candidates.
No, that's not true.
That's actually very much untrue.
Mike Pence, this is a weird 2024 Republican
primary already.
Mike Pence also spoke at the Iowa Roast and
Ride.
And it is actually stunning how Mike Pence
is embroiled in a battle with Ron DeSantis
for who could possibly be the least charismatic
candidate so far.
Here is Pence in a speech no one understood
nor cared about.
Speaker 2: It is great to be back at the roast
and ride I rode and I roasted on the ride.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Just absolutely electric delivery, as you
can see there.
Pence seemingly out of ideas.
He sort of, you know how on gun violence it's
like we've tried nothing and we're all out
of ideas is very often what you hear from
some on the right.
Pence so far has really tried nothing to justify
his candidacy, and he's just doing a little
bit of the DeSantis stuff, talking about Bud
Light and, you know, Target.
I don't think that this is if DeSantis can't
win with this stuff.
I don't know that Pence can win with the exact
same stuff.
Speaker 2: He also has to stand up for American
families.
Okay.
You know, the truth of the matter is we stand
here today.
Now, the radical left has been assaulting
our values and assaulting our families almost
as never before.
Speaker 1: Well, talk to me about how that's
going to get me a better paying job or more
job security, Mike.
Oh, right.
It won't.
It's the same nonsense DeSantis is peddling.
Speaker 2: But the great thing I've seen traveling
across this country is that the American people,
American people are onto.
Are they?
Just ask Bud Light.
Target.
And by the way, a message from Major League
Baseball.
Religious bigotry has no place in America's
pastime.
Speaker 1: You can tell he really means it
because he's moving his hands.
Oh.
All right.
And pens pointing to someone into the crowd
and mouthing, Thank you.
As you can see, this campaign does not exactly
have victory written all over it.
Here is Mike Pence interviewed there right
before, right after this thing.
He's wearing some kind of biker vest.
It might be leather, it might be pleather.
And asked about his big announcement, which
is scheduled for tomorrow.
And if anybody was worried that Mike Pence's
announcement might not be blessed by God,
he has been praying about it.
He notifies us.
Speaker 2: Right 50 miles into the state fairgrounds.
If that doesn't say I'm running for president,
I don't know what is.
Are you ready to make it official?
Well, we're looking forward to be back in
Iowa next Wednesday.
Yeah.
Now, Karen and I spent a lot of time over
the last two years reflecting and frankly
praying about where we make.
Speaker 1: The same God that told George W
Bush to go into Iraq when he prayed.
Is apparently advising the Pence's.
Speaker 2: Next serve our country after our
years in Congress or years as governor of
Indiana and years as vice president.
We've come to a decision.
I thought there'd be no better place to announce
our decision than right here in the Hawkeye
State.
Well, let me ask is right.
Speaker 1: Super, super exciting, as you can
see.
So, listen, how how is Mike?
But what is Mike Pence doing?
How is Mike Pence doing in this race?
The latest polling has Mike Pence at an anemic
3.8%.
I'll be honest, I don't even know how Mike
Pence has a path to getting ahead of Ron DeSantis.
Never mind catching Donald Trump.
I don't understand Mike Pence's argument for
even being a candidate.
If you didn't like the Trump administration.
Pence was part of that administration.
If you did like the Trump administration,
Trump's running and you can vote for Trump.
And if you didn't like Trump, but you want
someone with a viable path to victory, you've
got Ron DeSantis.
If you want a woman representing the Republican
Party, you've got Nikki Haley.
If you want a black guy representing the Republican
Party, you've got Tim Scott.
If you want a guy who's good at debating,
representing the Republican Party, you've
got Chris Christie.
I don't know what path there is for this guy.
And it makes me wonder why is he running at
all?
I haven't heard him justify it in any way.
That makes sense.
Maybe somebody in the audience has a clue.
Let me know.
Make sure you subscribe to the YouTube channel
YouTube.com, slash the David Pacman show.
That's a forward slash, folks.
Don't go
in with those back slashes.
Don't.
Don't you dare.